لحظات محرجه والتفاته فتحت الباب امام
التكهنات الكتف البارد الذي اعطاه الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين لوزير الدفاعه
سرجيه لم يفهم ما اذا كان اهانه ام غضبا
لكن البعض فسره على انه استياء ربما من
اداء شويغو اما موقف بوتين فيبقى واضحا
بانه لا انحياز للميليشيات على حساب
القوات النظاميه
النزاع بين مجموعه فاغنر والجيش بلغ اشده
وبوتين في مسعا لاخضاع القوات غير
النظاميه المقاتله في اوكرانيا لسلطه
وزاره الدفاع دعما لمبادره التي رفض
الانصياع لها مؤسس فاجنر بروجين وفق صحيفه
وتشير الصحيفه البريطانيه الى انه مع
خطوات بوتين التي تتماهى مع ما يريده
الجيش تزداد الصعوبات التي يواجهها
خاصه بعد ان تعهد بعدم العمل تحت قياده
شويغو صراحه وشكى ايضا من رغبه الجيش في
ابعاد مجموعته عن ساحه المعركه في
اوكرانيا
فمؤسس فاجنر يعتبر ان قواته هي مفتاح
القوه الروسيه في الحرب
ومع تجدد خلافات الجيش المرتبك ومجموعه
فاغنر صاحبه الانتصارات في اوكرانيا تبقى
المخاوف بشان مدى قدره بوتين على احتواء
وتطويع فاجنر لكن الخبراء ببواطن الامور
في روسيا يرون ان كل ما يحدث ان كان من
الجيش او فاجنر هو مزايدات ومناكفات هدفها
الاخير كسب رضاء ساكن الكرملين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات